[Applaudissements]
la présidence
conservant uniquement des pmp par
loyauté à l'égard de le ciel et quelques
médias à départ d'un club plus qu'à
laisser du temps pour aller
n'est plus ni moins rencontrer les gens
dans la circonscription dans laquelle je
vais me présenter aux élections
législatives sans étiquette après alors
merci fabrice di vizio d'être avec nous
alors ça c'est une surprise
franchement on l'avait pas annoncé dans
l'émission vous l'avait annoncé et c'est
fou ça nous a étonné donc vous allez
quitter la vie publique vous avez quitté
la vie publique à vous annoncer
maintenant votre candidature aux
élections législatives parce que depuis
le début vous nous dites que tout ce que
vous faites c'est pas politique commence
à tourner
en fait ces marques plus simple que ça
c'est qu'à un moment donné je voulais
dit je vais annoncer je peux retirer de
la vie publique ça fait un an et demi
que je parle et donc effectivement
géante en cette fin de match va
également que j'écoute j'ai entendu des
choses est abandonné peut-être que
l'idée c'est de se dire j'arrête de
parler et j'écoute j'arrête de parler et
je me tais et j'écoute en fait ce qui
m'a beaucoup posé problème depuis
quelques mois c'est que les gens vous
voyez en moins leader ce que j'ai
toujours refusé d'être jarry je l'exigé
te j'ai dit j'ai redit aux manifs les
gens qui applaudissent je leur ai dit
mme applaudissez pas il en est hors de
question mais a abandonné il ya aussi un
besoin de représentation il ya aussi un
besoin qu'on montre certaines choses et
les raisons qui pourraient me qui me
pousse finalement à poser ma candidature
c'est aussi celle qu'on a exposé dans le
sujet d'avant c'est que au fond vous
parlez tous on parle tous du confinement
du masque mais qui est allé demander aux
gens ce comment ils ont vécu qui est
allé une fois une seule fois leur
laisser la parole aux gens qui vivent
dans 50 mètres carrés à 5 les gens qui
effectivement depuis une année on parle
à leur place et moi le premier sans
doute eh bien peut-être que l'idée c'est
d'arrêter de parler et de leur laisser
la parole et peut-être que l'idée c'est
ça la notion de représentation et ben
c'est de se dire qu'en fait c'est eux
qu'il faut aujourd'hui entendent et plus
particulièrement effectivement dans ces
zones qui ont particulièrement souffert
de la crise mais fabrice parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui ont dit vous êtes
servi de tpm paix pour arriver à des
fins politiques gilles verdez notamment
1 leur répondez vous réveillez-vous là
ça vous plaît merci oui franchement
fabrice vous me décevez vous êtes une
girouette et je ne le pensais pas de
vous alors ici vous alors été pmp vous
venez à l'extérieur vous balancer ça
leur ferait que vous avez balancé sur
tpmc regardez regardez les mains des
extraits j'ai vraiment découvert j'ai
délégué départemental
j'ai découvert que c'était pas pour moi
en fait je crains politique que c'est
trop compliqué pour moi je t'ai passe
intelligente faire de la politique je ne
comprenais pas tout à ce qui se passait
à ce qui se disait je ne comprenais pas
comment d'un côté on pouvait se dire
sarko sceptiques et faire faire campagne
contre sarko scepticisme ce qui était
bien mon positionnement du sarko
scepticisme pour ensuite être ministre
de nicolas sarkozy tout en disant mais
c'est c'est la consécration du sarko
sceptisme la mobiliser madame boutin
maquela de zombo c'est comme les
plateaux della mois à l'honneur je
connaissais pas à mouiller je me dis je
vais faire sur un amas promo du thomas
promotion à nunoa merci
mais mais je les connais c'est pas ces
gens-là mois alors c'est vrai que ça a
été mal pris a
été mal pris de dire que je ne
connaissais pas non non non je garde ma
promotion
non il ya énormément de condescendance
et mépris dans la faute face alors non
le seul mépris qu'affiche déterminé à la
baisse donc vous dites à nos matchs je
connaissais pas comme et franchement
comme ça on va se coucher hanouna comme
si j'en avais besoin mais vous êtes
servi pendant plus d'un an avec des
machines à monaco alors attendez je vais
répondre à ça rennais c'est généralement
grâce à vous que j'aille répondre à ça
on pourrait proposer le prennent à
l'envers peut-être que l'émission s'est
servi de moi aussi parce que a priori si
j'étais maire chroniqueur de l'année
c'est peut-être que vous avez augmenté
nos parts de marché alors donnez moi
mais
j'attends du jeu j'attends d'une
émission pour exister non mais est ce
que vous savez jamais tenu un double
langage point d'entrée
pour toujours le vatican ii mais sans
que vous étiez aux côtés de kristin
booth mais vous le découvrez parce que
nous voulions ou non là vous vous
découvrez vous le découvrez parce que
manifestement vous ne vous intéressez
pas à ce que je dis depuis un an et demi
mardi ce que j'ai dit est public depuis
un an et demi je vous ai dit d'ailleurs
le bout des missions tout à l'heure qui
par erreur et passez vous le dit c'était
pas fait pour moi parce qu'il y avait un
problème de cohérence c'est tout mathieu
qu'est ce que tu en penses la vérité
c'est que on fait preuve pendant pendant
un an il ya eu une passe et les terres
il ya une vague ça locaux vides et que
du coup bah c'est parfait pour vous
parce que ça vous a permis du coup
d'exister malheureusement le pass
sanitaire est entré un petit peu de
partir le coc vide dieu merci est en
train alors si les pensées
tribu d'ouvriers et pour une heure et
votre ego de
la réputée perd les deux premières comme
député ps de l'apparat ya la politique
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'ici c'est
vrai mais excusez moi il ya plus tp mp
je vous rappelle que c'est moi qui ai
dit je venais +1 et je rappelle que
c'est la prod qui m'a demandé de revenir
au passage à chaque fois je suis parti
d'ici on va pas se tromper non plus à
chaque fois je partis d'ici j'ai reçu un
appel de la prod on a eu de longues
discussions et qui m'ont convaincu de
revenir donc à un moment si vous voulez
moi je veux bien premier élément
deuxième élément vous voyez pourquoi
est-ce que je pense que c'est urgent
d'aller porter une parole publique et
d'écouter les gens parce que si
effectivement vous étiez un peu malin
vous ne sauriez que le pass annie terre
il en train de s'installer dans le
paysage et que c'est bien ça qui pose
problème ce qui si vous étiez un peu
malin vous sauriez que le problème c'est
que le pass sanitaires il va être
appliquée aux conditions climatiques
dans quelques mois et le jrc dont je ne
pouvais pas offensant de penser que
c'est ce que j'aime et je dire pour le
coup le giec pour le coup est venu vous
dire que ma c'est génial on pensait pas
que les gens pourraient soumettre plus
facile facilement et que donc on va
appliquer les mêmes règles au climat
maintenant je vais vous dire je termine
sur ce point il ya un point qui est très
clair je veux dire c'est que au fond ce
qui m'amuse c'est que ça fait cinq
minutes qu'on parle de moi alors que
fondamentalement
personne m'a même demandé encore où je
me présentais et pourquoi je me
présentais et vous parlez de médecins
attendent également vous présenter
le seul mépris que je vois ici c'est de
votre part pour la part effectivement de
tous ceux qui m'ont demandé d'être
candidat quelle pression absolument pas
de le savoir médaillés bah oui ça
intéresse pas ou que vous l'avez vous
l'avez évoqué largement sur les réseaux
c'est pour ça que je me suis revenir
vous avez dit notamment à la fois je
fais je ne veux pas faire de politique
mais je n'ai que je me présente journée
mais je vais quand même un devoir de lui
mais je termine mais je vais quand même
en faire un tout petit peu mais ça met
les législatives je ne suis je ne suis
pas à continuer avec florian philippot
mais quand même il va quand même un
petit peu mais des pas ce que c'est je
vais utiliser ces équipes de campagne
nous avons finalement donc si vous
n'êtes pas prêt excusez moi est le seul
mépris que je vois dans ses missions ses
lois votre à mon égard
absolument si vous voyez qui était si
vous croyez tonnes excusez moi si vous
présentez comme à marseille mais par
pitié fabrice hénon et vous voyez drôle
vous croyez qu effectivement les gens
c'est là pendant un an et demi je le
sais la télé
ils le savaient pas ce que je voulais
dire bah oui
vous savez pas ce que je voulais des
conflits partiellement dans les coups de
10 heures et vous n'êtes pas qu'une
source a comparé ce que mes joueurs
aient la décence voyez il y avait
peut-être que je vous ai dits
confidentiels non non alors taisez vous
je ne laisse pas passer ça là je n'ai
pas passer sa chance à ces dégâts c'est
moi que ça c'est dégueulasse on m'avait
dit je vous donne une information of je
fais journal et j'ai respecté alors ça
c'est annonce ainsi j'ai arrêté cyril
année dit il annoncera chez nous dans
quelques mois gérer que j'ai donc quel
département abc vous c'est pas vrai
c'est vrai qu'ils ont dit mais
manifestement ça ne vous intéresse mais
si ça cadors dessus phase des poules
j'ai un moment donné effectivement votre
problème chers amis c'est la
starification vous traitez de stars mais
le problème est effectivement c'est vous
qui faites la star
alors que alors que fondamentalement ça
vous a pas effleuré que peux tu avais
dit l'hôte une prétendue mars et tous
ont mis bien
j'y viens il se présente en
seine saint denis
[Applaudissements]
il amène et l'invite rambouillet et ceux
présentant samedi pour faire taire m
malaisé vous savez de ma vie allez-y je
vous écoute cave ou laminé rambouillet
vous jouez encore seine saint denis je
viens de rambouillet a été ma vie de
rambouillet et emma beal avait promis à
effectivement ma vie
vous comprenez vous que vous savez de
rambouillet jouer présentant cinq jeunes
ni maître olivier panis et chez moi
cette année j'ai vécu toute ma vie j'ai
rêvé que cette ceni je les connais parce
que pendant que vous disserter sur le co
vide pas tant que vous disent athées son
coût filmant les mecs de seine samedi
ils ont pris en pleine garrigue au vide
et des boucles en fuite et qu'elle sert
d'entrée mission est d'être au bord 4
même si tu vas quelles circonstances
avez vous [ __ ] là bas ça m'intéresse
de savoir les joueurs parce que vous
pensez qu effectivement ça va ça nous
intéresse bah oui il est hors de
question que je vous dise quoi que ce
soit je vais en seine saint denis est
également à noter je voulais dire
j'avais en seine-saint-denis dont vous
avez demandé
je vais vous dire vous voyez il est là
le problème c'est qu'en fait oui c'est
ça qui est toujours massive sur un point
cyril c'est que c'est sympa qu'on soit
connue mais vraiment
je suis pas d'accord ça vous plaisait je
vois c'est important qu'on fasse
un pas qu'on soit connue parce que comme
quoi il faut ça jamais s'arrêter à
superficie des choses faut jamais
s'arrêter on dira ce qu'on voit c'est un
texte écrit ce que je vois avec une
écorce l'essentiel est invisible aux
yeux heureusement que je vous ai connus
les uns et les autres individuellement
parce que au moins ce que ça veut dire
c'est que vous n'êtes pas conforme à
l'image que vous renvoyez moi au moins
j'ai cette délicatesse de dire que vous
n'êtes pas conforme à l'image que vous
en voyez vous faire connaître et
revenons ici ça y est maintenant
mais par contre vous allez voir explique
mme sadou veille j'avais mené un combat
pendant des mois et des mois il va
falloir maintenant aux états unis a
échappé sa maigre en défense étaient les
général diva division pardon vous êtes
en train de définir un agenda
fabrice di vizio que j'aime beaucoup je
vous le dis même s'il n'est pas toujours
tendre avec moi sur les réseaux sociaux
ni dans des villes à la vigne avec vous
mais je vais vous savez pourquoi
pourquoi parce que je suis libre et que
voir jardinage et quand j'ai un truc à
dire je le lis points parce que moi je
viens je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
que moi je viens d'un milieu dans lequel
on se balance et c'est le prix à la
gueule mais à la fin on s'est bien passé
pour moi j'en freedent sans sucre on se
balance après la gueule tout journée
vraiment mais à la fin quand on a besoin
les uns des autres on est toujours là
bas
ça s'appelle non mais moi c'est vrai que
tous les deux on peut s'engueuler mais
où on sait que voilà aussi que vous
savez que vous aime beaucoup non mais
c'est vrai et je veux dire moi je viens
d'une famille dans laquelle on se tape
sur la gueule à longueur de journée mais
là pas de la fin mai à la fin de la
feinte et reprend l'ergonomie dieu mais
à la
fin de la fin quand l'un de nous a
besoin de l'autre on est toujours
présent alors toujours s'il vous plaît
sur fabrice di vizio il y en a qui ont
eu le sentiment qui s'est servi des pmp
pour arriver à des fins politiques
est-ce que vous c'est votre sentiment à
merveille pas le sentiment quand même de
prendre un peu le melon la qui tous
alors suisse et wade père né paie alors
moi j'ai pas le melon je te pète c'est
ça je me suis ici à vis du tpm paix
pendant que le papa est ce que vous
rendez compte du pouvoir que vous êtes
tribus et les gars quand même quoi est
ce que vous vous rendez compte que j'en
dis politiqué aggravantes et
png par l'international
et si tu pouvais aller acheter des
aubergines tranquille au mas et alors
parce que vous confondez d'eau chaude à
mons avant qu'il arrive la police parce
que pour vous serait ce que pour avril
parce que des mecs me croise dans la rue
et me prenne ans elle vit vous pensez
vous fassiez vous pensez qu'ils étaient
classés saint geours y aider marie a
fait notoriété est fabriquée même
s'inquiéter ça a un rapport avec
l'élection
pour quelques uns de mes koné pour nous
donner je vous parle et vous c'est moi
m'en excuser moi d'abord vous ne m'avez
pas invité pour que je me connaissent
mais parce que vous me connaissiez
premiers éléments parce que dans cette
crise j'ai été présent adam vous ai
inventées bbc vous m'avez vu quoi ça n'a
rien à voir et on a pris pas ce côté
broncy voilà acte avait des arguments
d'accord la monnaie n'ont été ni citée
en mai n'ont pas ma boîte et pourquoi
parce que rome la démarche balisée et
que j'étais avocat de raout et que parce
que j'ai conduit à mise en examen de
buzeins elle pour ça qu'on a invité
parce que dans cette crise j'avais une
préexistence premiers éléments deuxième
élément je crois que vous confondez la
politique et de la télé réalité sera dit
ça bien c'est ça le problème même si
vous croyez que la notoriété suffit à
vous faire élire vous avez rien compris
ce qui vous fait élire c'est la capacité
à écouter les gens à identifier leurs
problèmes et apporter des commencements
de solutions de votre chalet et grâce à
la notoriété vous avez vous
étonnez vous avez tort m m il ya la mer
il ya ma mère qui lui mais il me met
quand même fait lui la gueule bah non
c'est ma dans la famille mais elle vous
adore en plus vrai voyez comme quoi
voilà je vous dire que c'est inventé que
tout bien j'aurais pas venu vous êtes un
personnage de télé réalité en fait vous
êtes un pitre médiatique vous êtes un
moulin à vent
[Musique]
toute l'année vous vous présentez comme
le porte parole de la souffrance des
gens excusé mais qu'est ce que vous en
savez vous aussi vous avez dit moi je
comprends les gens qu'ils auront donc
c'est un rêve pour tablettes et moi mais
ils n'ont pas fait ce que monsieur
division messieurs division exigeant est
ce que monsieur division et donc au
dessus des lois il exige que les
chroniqueurs et en plus de leurs passes
annie terre un test pcr je précise non
absolument pas pardon maintenant j'ai
pas accepter parce que j'ai un masque
même étant dit ça c'est ça c'est une
blague mais non mais vous excusez moi le
producteur maintenant que tout le monde
c'était tester non ok ça ne marche pas
[Applaudissements]
à
quoi donc fébrilement la production et
mais le public
la production a donc menti et et je veux
les non juifs
à ne pas te dire ça on a un contrat
ensemble le contrat c'est qu'on se croit
condamnant les gens sont dans le contrat
le contrat c'est que je viens en plateau
si tout le monde se soumet à passer à
tout sous ben voilà je mets un test l'a
fait manifestement
elle est là mais elle venait je me fous
de ce marché vaccinaux bengale à labège
division il ya une loi mais s'est dit
listeria pas encore les divisions même
si vous présentez vous à partir de loi
saperait mme de mensonge mais non pas
qu'ils n'ont pas produit tu m'as menti
il a menti je dirais pas menti théo théo
théo rosell je trouve assez petit théo
m'a dit
hier j'ai dit moi
ça drôle et richard matin maintenant
scurati trouve ça dingue drôle demandé
s'il voulait pas s il ne voulait pas que
j'ai déballé montréal et la télé révèle
une milice à égalité moi même je taxé
les publics il a pas eu un test en moins
qu'ils avaient la même jean pas de
panique chez les sms de théo n'ont pas
manqué
mais puisque je vais te dire moi
géraldine qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait parce que j'ai un deal ne veut pas
se faire tester pourquoi mais parce que
moi je vais là-bas j'en ai pour c'est un
mec de la production on impose un
passani terre parce que c'est la loi
ouais voilà c'est réaliste et donc je
respecte la loi la loi il n'y a aucun
trou de la soie le vaccin soit sp sert
parfaitement mais bon on est remis du
coc vide bon donc moi j'ai mon mea
vaccination qui en avril avait
parfaitement muselé comme vous imposiez
non non non non non vous avez de même
pour être très aimée dinars il est et je
n'ai rien exigé la preuve j'ai des sms
ou jeudi ce soir je viens dehors si tu
veux que je vienne et il m'a dit non
tous les chroniqueurs se font tester et
vendredi dernier tu as quelqu'un n'est
ce pas à mes vingt dix derniers mois
j'ai dit je reste dehors il m'a dit non
oui effectivement c'est souvent tout se
fait à trier c'est assister
voilà là au mois par exemple moi j'ai
volontiers parce que j'avais envie de
dialoguer avec vous c'était votre
volonté donc je les fais je comprends
tout à fait ce que dit my mojo copine
géraldine dragon
très honnêtement je ne sais pas moi j'ai
déjà terminé je termine juste une
question nous on l'a fait parce que on
va la corruption en exemple pour la
teneur la production non mais j'ai
surmonté la bri avez vous déjà entendu
mes fans ans vous saviez très bien si on
pouvait pas que le public là ils ont
tous et un masque et un pass and i ter à
la et pourrait vous n'avez pas demandé à
ce que le public en plus un test pcr et
ben moi je vois mal les chroniqueurs
vous et moi le faire excusez moi je veux
dire on a un contrat ce contrat il me
moi j'ai dit je viens dehors on me dit
non tous les chroniqueurs ont accepté de
se faire tester je découvre sur le
plateau que c'est pas le cas vous
m'excusez quand même si on appelle ça un
mensonge
victime méprise là c'est un peu
méprisant
définition celle ordonnée prime et c'est
peut-être ça le râble axios et disent ne
présenter que l'électrique ans
d'interner d'entre eux loin de la
pression mais c'est à valoir madame
monsieur vous dit enfin j'ai pas le
belge géraldine c'est vrai la production
me dis que vous faites tester c'est pas
le cas et c'est moi qui suis responsable
en rien responsable de rien
fabrice à les suivait son sable de vous
avoir cru ah oui oui mais
si ça t'amuse tu vois si lille attend
tout à l'heure tu déclarais ton amitié
oui si c'est comme ça tu traites et amis
on va avoir un problème elle a de
la gueule
n'est pas notre moi je veux dire
concrètement non je suis allé on joue
pas avec ça mais c'est un éventail de la
gueule on joue pas avec ça je passais
règles sanitaires on a posé on a posé
des conditions en ce
jeudi en l'occurrence guichet en
l'occurrence théo me dis que tout le
monde était testée c'est pas le cas
c'est un trop bien là le braille alors
donc fabrice tu veux quitter plateau
mais moi je crois qu'on est blessé
lockheed et platon et socrate en
synthèse les hongrois merci à la fac il
ya des fois où je suis vraiment désolé
et je suis vraiment désolé je suis
vraiment désolé sur un point c'est que
j'avais pensé que le débat était
possible il suggéré et vous allez faire
venir des études magail pas du tout vous
êtes une marguerite attendre s'attaque
laden meule à dire en plateau mais
encore effectivement quand tu me dis que
tous les chroniqueurs se font tester et
que c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
toujours détesté voirie appareils
doivent réparer on
voit que tu viens ce fait décidé moi
c'est juste dans l aveyron gérer
visiophone je suis témoins lé bisiaux
fob j'ai entendu j'ai entendu je suis
pas non plus complètement congelé un
décret division c'est bon bon ben on
regarde vous croyez
jeudi le débat est réglé fabrice jeudi à
la clé moi je voudrais pas te dire syrie
je trouvais que cette émission avait
cécile intéressant ah oui elle était
populaire oui bah oui on sent
effectivement véritablement latin du mot
j'adopte finalement ce que je découvre
c'est que ceux qui disent qu'en fait je
suis le pitre de service et combien du
tout un conte est bon
chaque fois que tu viens je
sais faire tester fabrier tu peux
prendre sa légitime mais pouvait
comprendre monsieur passion play que
j'aime dans l'histoire comme un problème
lorsque la production vous dites mémoire
les fans c'était vrai que c'est pas le
cas mais quand même le coup de 11 heures
pour iphone macbook
pro
groupama fabrice lhomme le
questionnaire donc c'est pas donc j'ai
dit que je lui ai fait pas bien son
personnage
j'ai compris que la guerre dans un cas
comme ça concerne
c'est pour ça c'est grave mais c'est pas
grave j'aime bien vient pas de billets
pas de problème
je voudrais chers et non fondamentales
vous avez raison fabrice geste à dire
que moi j'ai jamais
facile moi j'ai posé jeudi pour mieux
accepter mes conditions vous l'aviez dit
pour
toi
[Applaudissements]
moi ce soir il était prévu que je sois
dehors chine ma vie et où personne n'a
accepté de se faire tester
sais pas qui pokou c'est un mensonge
nord
est ce que tu peux ce que nicolas
pernikoff tu veux dire derniers mois
fabrication non mais j'aimerais juste
dire quelque chose c'est que vous êtes
mais on est venu lé manière dialoguer
pardon on m'a dit que vous veniez
dialoguer avec nous comment alors on a
fait 15 minutes où on vous entendu
gesticuler dans tous les sens mais on a
toi dois vous le dire non mais on n'a
rien de méchant mais parce que je vous
aime bien en foirant voir un kawa oui on
a toujours au fond oui nous font mal et
bien oui parce que je pense que
vous avez profité d'une situation sont
riches et bravo pour moi vous êtes très
forte
et je termine pour l'instant que
j'espérais c'était ce soir dialoguer un
petit peu à existe alors comprendre
comment cet arrêt la douane très
politique je me souviens encore il ya
une semaine vous traitiez certains
soignants 2d binh de mémoire là j'avais
envie d'essayer de comprendre
ça c'est vous qui le faites pas moi
enfin petite croix depuis le début et
wayan qui accompagne depuis sa
déclaration il ya des choses que je suis
je veux dire à un moment donné il ya un
concept que vous ne semblez pas
maîtrisés c'est celui de la liberté
parce que la vérité je vous la donne et
la vérité c'est que moi tu es pmp ou pas
santé pmp j'existe quand même mal à moi
[Applaudissements]
ce
qu'il s'est passé ce soit idée n'est pas
de ça va c'est
[Musique]
l'exacte vérité pas avec fabrice on
n'arrive pas à quoi tout le monde a
passé le tapis enfin tout le monde sauf
le grand pardon d'annoncer plus tout le
monde
soit bien mais oui mais certaines des
faux négatifs
alors et bayal au même étage et
aujourd'hui c'était un parfait alors
vous me demandez mettre un masque à
l'aller vous croyez que vous avez envie
qu'on a tout fait vrai martiaux sanon
tout était parfait non mais je veux dire
à tomber
x et vous êtes
là là là vous faites alors je vous dis
théo déjà je pense n'était pas au
courant pas secourir l'île est ce que
vous l'avez bien sûr pas moi je dis
toujours toi alors il le savait bon bah
ils le savaient donc ce alors tu te vois
tu pas mais il
va tu veux je te dise je t'aime
tellement qui n'a pas voulu te le dire
eh ben ça s'appelle un mensonge mais non
on trouve que c'est une omission je
passe pourquoi moi tu pensé qu on a
effectivement des règles moi je n'impose
à personne mérite mais vous me posez les
beautés la note qu'elle n'a pas voulu se
soumettre elle a pas aujourd'hui de m
elle devrait bien pouvoir chinois mais
c'est à gerald but mais je l'aimais je
vous produire qu'ils coupent la lettre
laissée par tout le monde le problème
effectivement c'est carrément donné il
ya des règles et ces règles n'ont pas
été respectées je me prenais pour un con
non non ça va alors se dire ça dit qu'on
doit jouer face à brassac fait de la
peine c'est tu dis ça bah moi c'est
lorsqu'il peut l'appeler fait tout pour
un con non ce qui me fait de la peine
c'est tout à l'heure combien m'expliquer
que j'ai besoin tpp pour exister parce
que manifestement vous comprenez rien ce
que je vous dise
sabrina mené notoriété
nouvelle vague ok j'en fasse autorité
sinon message en face à emmanuel macron
l'inconnu et désorientée elle a fait
beaucoup de télé il a fait beaucoup de
trucs jour des naseaux alors je me suis
dit et si fais moi je me sens quelque
chose je préfère réserver au tnt comme
mckinsey à la limite parce que moi tpb
la tuer personne de qui de mckinsey
macintosh laisse tomber
le fait est que ce n'est pas normal dans
cette histoire vous parler de dialogue
j'en conviens mais ça c'est pas du
dialogue cette soirée quand on le dit
c'est mon choix c'est pas du dialogue
cher ami tu veux partir je m'en vais
c'est tout tu vas ou non c'est pas ton
programme je vais chez moi tu vas pas
une chicha parce que
ce dôme où son état de rendre compte en
fait il ya un point jeudi à passer pour
l'hystérique de service ne démarre
c'est bon il faut pas mathieu ses
squares drôle mais non on est pas
[Applaudissements]
et
les sujets des sujets comme ça qui sont
un peu trop sérieux pour vous c'est bon
on donnait à prix sa confiance et a
confiance risque pareil on va elle fera
le fera elle ne sera pas là la preuve
absolue de toute façon à partir de
maintenant mais à paris je serais pas là
elles vont être plus rare pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'est ce qui
va se passer si un csa vallée des contes
et un an il
indiqué et dans cette partie alors aulas
quel parfum est très pratique un parti
mais vous êtes chez à cuire comme moi
vous prenez vous pour tous en réalité je
suis pas un qr code je suis pas un mec
qui fait que je fais un code-barres
ouais non mais on vous a beaucoup vie
avec monsieur fier alors on m'a beaucoup
mieux parce que filippo dans beaucoup de
christine boutin elle m'a beaucoup plu
est un consensus vise à certains égards
à certains moments avec les communistes
à d'autres mais c'est ça la liberté
d'accord la liberté c'est pour dialoguer
avec tout le monde avec 13 ex comme
celle où l'extrémiste de services en
avance à son équipe de voix c'est vous
parce que vous voudrez que du mépris
pour tout le monde doit pas laisser ça
qui conduisent extrême c'est le mépris
ni aucun agent toujours été respectée
personnes dans l'histoire si vous
respectez vraiment on avait on avait un
deal ce deal effectivement moi je les
retiens
c'est tout si derrière ça vous mettez le
respect c'est bien là on en est là parce
que vous n'avez aucune idée ce que c'est
que le respect c'est pour donner des
leçons
à tous
je dis à vous plaît effectivement des
leçons à moi que florian philippot
florian philippot on n'a plus cette boue
dans la crise
par rapport à vous feriez filippo giunta
l'est davantage c'est que tous les
samedis il permet à des gens de se
sentir bien et les samedis
que vous voulez méprise et c'est ça
qui va s'y passe faudrait il voulait
considérer qu'ils passent et adore tu en
train de chier une pendule n'aurait non
non non c'est pas un film tendu pour un
match je suis le problème colas cyril
votre problème non non on en dialogue
mais votre problème c'est
qu'effectivement un moment donné on a un
contrat on en a pas si vous savez pas ce
que c'est qu'un contrat c'est que je
suis désolé pour vous mais j'y peux rien
moi j'ai posé des conditions est présent
pas été respectés s'est érodée en a tant
que ça parce que ça fait quand même un
quart d'heure que vous êtes là où
exactement
robert fabrice ont l'air on a dû tout
petit navire [ __ ]
mais parce que c'est pas pour qui s'y
présente sans étiquette
ni prades années gucci mais sans
critiquer il a vraiment même pas qui
habille rien mais le prix demandé
peut-être quoi rappeler le pour y
demander
si on perd on se calme